collomb
[Musique]
des cartels c'est une affaire de
succession
du jour où pablo a été tué le cartel de
cali est devenu l'ennemi public numéro
un les affaires avaient prospéré et
c'était devenu le plus grand cartel de
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
c'était la major company de la cocaïne
il agirait comme une des 500 plus
grosses entreprises mondiales
[Musique]
content que tu sois de retour baigneurs
l'américain des projets pour la colombe
et un nouveau bain de sang les
compliquerait c'est quoi le plan on fera
autrement ac alliés
tout ce que toi en temps prenant aux
barons calice et plus de canard les gens
veulent voir les parents menottés c'est
exactement ce qu'ils ont
m erreur
si vous voulez avoir le cartel faut
qu'on se fasse confiance
[Musique]
voilà
pour faire tomber le cartel de cali
[Musique]
fallait être cinglé stupide téméraires
et en même temps
très chanceux
[Musique]